hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights of bug
boys 3 now we're onto the sixth shot
[ __ ] which has been a bit of a bear to
get through like I've said before I
don't drink often like it's not that I'm
a huge fan of drinking but this is
actually a lot of fun well I will say
something but let me take the shottsford
cheers everybody out there wanna know
you are loved and you can do whatever
you want top of the mornin Kenya okay
anyway
what I was gonna say is I wanted to make
sure that people know I don't know how
long I have left in this game but if I
have to go through every single vent to
get to the office which i think is what
it said I had to do then it's gonna take
a while and I might have another part
after this which every other one before
it's been six parts five nights of
everybody wanting to that is my last
shot and here's why I'm not here to
encourage people to drink excessively
and I know my limit so what I say about
drinking it like you should drink
responsibly if you're of age to drink or
if you're not yet of age to drink like
when you do drink don't let anyone
pressure you into drinking more than
you're comfortable with like six shots
that's the max I'm comfortable with
because after that I become like sick
and nauseous and it's not a good time so
I wanna make sure there's still a good
time a good time I got time and as I'm
playing this game you know if there are
more part after that I'm just gonna ride
out my drunkenness for the rest of it
but I want to make sure I'm not here to
try to celebrate excessive drinking
that's not the point here I'm here to
show that drinking responsibly can be
fun and you don't even need to drink to
have fun but five nights of [ __ ] boys
let's do this where the hell am i I
blocked up I'm mMmmm it's our way to
turn off the mini-map yeah probably not
okay here we go let's beat the engine
again for some reason excuse me
fan security caesium appeared it didn't
really appear I kind of snuck up on it
with except for sneaking up on it I
didn't you
boom boom boom boom and then it's gonna
push me away and then the fireball comes
and when the fireball is coming I'm
supposed to run away from it whereas me
I didn't do that okay so okay so I'm
here I can actually keep saving okay
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
preemptively
uh-oh that's not a one okay I can't do
that one okay so I thought I might be
needed to preemptively do that one so
that I could have a path to run away in
case the fire followed me but that's
stupid the fire wouldn't follow me why
would it when one reason would that be a
thing that happens oh I forgot I can't
eat the pizza because he does that first
okay but I mean so long as I attack
first I'm fine with that ma'am Oh
critical yet baby when are you gonna
push me away for fire you're spread
bombs aren't the same don't do that hey
come on come on okay I'll be back there
we go there we go okay that's it that's
the thing oh no that's not the thing oh
okay okay
BAM and then I gotta go away go away
going getting getting in gone gone gone
who where am i where am I can't see whoa
what I didn't know the fire could follow
me who do these things were a thing I
couldn't actually see where I was
because I was blocked by the new banner
but it's a good thing I saved where I
did cuz otherwise
it'd be okay there we go that's what I
need to do so I need to open up that
Avenue so I can run away from the fire
and then I can probably come back once I
go outside to the vent outside of it
yeah yes I'm so good at things here we
go here we go
push me away that's okay I'm gonna go
and save the day and then I'm gonna make
a thing out of clay and then I'm gonna
have a wonderful day oh boy look at me
go I I just oh crap I didn't know I
didn't know oh that was a close one
is there gonna be another I think
there's gonna be more oh my god Clos du
Clos babar du Clos du close I'm gonna
come around I'm gonna get sure oh I
can't go through this one exactly what I
needed to do unless I didn't need to go
through this van that I needed to go
through another one this one doesn't
even leave to the hallway oh it's house
okay guys I got you I forgot that
there's only one vent that actually
leads to the the office so I need to go
through the office to be able to do oh
what's that what's that turn on the
sprinkler sure I'll do that fine
yeah evidently well that did oh okay
okay I'll be back when I get to the
place where I need to go baby no I don't
know if the sprinkler system is probably
gonna hurt spring-trap here because
something tells me that water and
electronics aren't gonna mix whoa that's
not a sprinkler that's fog as is fog
from the fire being put out by the
sprinkler system haha
observation I'm pretty drunk that's why
I know my limit and that's why I
encourage you guys to not drink more
than you need to
cuz excessive drinking is very bad very
bad does bad things to you God don't let
that happen
Oh tits oh it did wrong in it wrong in
it wrong i god damn and I used a soda
instead of okay that's fine okay I'm
fine by that her I thought he was gonna
cause a problem for me but apparently
not but I did waste a soda it's not like
I don't have a lot of them but I don't
like to waste when I might have more
whoa don't do that that's scary I don't
like that I also am running into the
problem where I'm quite under level what
I think I should be even though I farmed
a lot I feel like you know the numbers
that were represented in the shadow
world or whatever it was those uh those
uh those yeah those are yeah so yeah
even watching your health bar I did it I
[ __ ] yeah all right time to go into the
event you where I need to be Wow sixty
six thousand thirty five that's not bad
I think the only max on there was forty
right so I guess I'm not too far off now
I am sad that I didn't see like the
Easter Egg boss it was probably the
puppet and if I wanted to be the puppet
I would add a level up a lot yes I did
why am I here
wait no why am I here what why am i
walking so slowly huh what oh oh i'm
reenacting the game oh i'm walking
slowly to the office i'm making him very
skit why did it why was
necessary some some time ago
yes I have located the objects required
for the ritual
I must retrieve them oh I thought I was
gonna be playing as Balloon Boy
hello puppet are you not gonna be
bothering me anymore oh okay
cutscene then who's dead us whoa hey
yeah yeah general idea I don't know
what's going on here that's rather
bizarre okay I pop it a bap
eat my [ __ ] you ain't counting down no
more big boy
am I supposed to be Oh perhaps I'm
supposed to be doing something here you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah your man's life oh
he's spring-trap the bad guy oh it's
still locked
I can't run that's why I'm walking very
slowly I literally cannot run a shart
all I should have taken the shortcut but
I want to make sure that I'm not missing
anything looks good here looks good
there oh no I have a plan and you will
do it okay or whatever you say bloom boy
I'm all ears did spring grab the bunny
for the third part of my strategic
masterpiece there is only one thing you
need did you I need you to hijack this
game from that guy Oh
ah I'm starting to piece it together Oh
spring crap Ward's the bad guy uh yeah I
think you are mistaken I am NOT Freddie
I am exactly not Freddie you need to
appreciate how North Freddie I am Oh
what is that whoa whoa is that it knows
that someone zoom that in someone crop
that out
someone enhance set zoom zoom we're
being hacked two people on this keyboard
we got to go okay hello
you got oh well I guess I kind of
understood that spring-trap was bad
because of you know purple guy and all
that being the murderer of children and
bad stuff in general just yo all-around
no good doer you know what I mean oh
this is so cool
it is weird because like it's following
the light and before I go it's following
like the story of five nights at
Freddy's 3 better than like the other oh
hey what's going holy crap Ola
hello Balloon Boy do you know what to do
that bean man
I think lapping means like bunny
anything there's something I you you bet
on foo me okay Oh
the slow reveal the ultimate ending the
final sacrifice the Stars a swag swag
swag swag aroni oh we got thrown into a
fuck-boy
oh hey Balloon Boy okay
okay well then I guess that's it
and in fact 1x1
I'm only halfway done what a bunch of
baloney
and so spring-trap was a huge piece of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] up everything how dare
he what a douche
I can't believe and him so long standing
in his way he set up all of the cameras
to deter any trespassers from ruining
his plans oh you oh no only one has the
power to stop him No oh hey ha ha ha
really hey I play as golden Freddy the
boss that I beat from the first game who
wanted to give some dicks just for no
reason
I really don't know am i like
legitimately like only halfway through
this game a portal appeared somewhere
what is that supposed to mean all right
what's up gold Freddy baby
thanks chipper ok oh I'm level one again
I'm level one
[Music]
summons what does summons mean did I
always have what is happening I don't
get it
am I really he sounds like a badass but
I don't know what's happening oh okay oh
maybe this is gonna go quicker than I
thought it was hey how's it going
oh you look modern and interesting I'm
gonna give some dicks uh-huh really Oh
am i miss Mina oh hey hey spring douche
hey douche wrap yeah he's very
persistent what he's gonna do [ __ ] you
that's the idea okay
Oh balloons oh oh yeah Balloon Boy
okay what is summoned I don't know what
that is but it sounds way better than
whatever the hell I had okay I guess I
don't know how much health they have so
I don't have a lot of health I might as
well just do the big one on the big guy
hey-oh
oh that does like nothing
well damn okay this doesn't seem fair oh
okay I'm gonna die is that how this is
all right see where this amazing going
Freddy was fully healed good someone
only lasts a few turns use it wisely as
it disappears when the battle is over
will also fade if golden Freddy perishes
okay I'm gonna get a gamma trigger up in
this baby Oh
poison stoned top out of doom this is
awesome oh wow it even brought me a
whole bunch of crap
cool awesome okay so was that a powerful
three hit attack buh-buh-buh-buh-buh oh
is it like randomized oh we got
everybody oh we got everybody you ain't
got nothing on me baby I'm a freakin
gangsta don't Freddy use guard you let
everyone else do the job because frankly
I don't know what you can do that would
probably be better than what's going on
okay so I'm just gonna have party at
screen shots key oh my goodness that's
awesome oh I think he's like done isn't
he he's already like done oh man top how
to do doesn't even take any mana that's
so cool that's so cool he's so badass
that's so cool that's nuts
alright then a [ __ ] Z in my [ __ ] got
a massive HP MP was good great maybe the
idea is that I'm supposed to just like
plow through all this oh pardon what's
happening
why whoa what
[Music]
well I have the perfect idea
is it possible that five nights of [ __ ]
boys has a deeper more meaningful story
than actually five nights at Freddy's 3
what the [ __ ] that's like blowing my
mind
holy [ __ ] okay so I need to heal up am I
like am I like losing my mind here am I
wrong visibly this is amazing this is
awesome what is that oh oh it's nothing
oh it's a jukebox oh I like I like the
normal ambiance better okay so I guess I
just got a procedurally kick the ass of
every camera in here wait let me make
sure that's true okay I can move forward
now at least I don't have the puppet to
worry about which also means that I was
supposed to beat the puppet
oh why is this back this wasn't here
before
hello can I open this out corners what
the hi
I was just accustomed to the fact that
there was a dragon there though what the
hell's Hydra dildo does it have like
nine heads in every time you cut one
okay so what is this alright
[Music]
three-headed dragon dildo who's not a
joke that's amazing
I got a hollow I don't know what that
means but I got it okay now I can play
these right
mangles esoteric quest oh absolutely I
want to play that oh definitely yes
bow-bow oh this is actually fun that's
actually pretty cool I mean it's not
incredibly well-made but I mean for what
it is it's not bad at all when the world
this link this 5.8 fuckboys 3 is so much
better than the other ones like not that
the other ones were bad but it's like so
much more involved and interesting what
insult world is happening whoa wait whoa
wait wait Balloon Boy there what do you
think you're doing
oh you think you know I got my hands
crisscross because I need to double tap
whistle with my right hand actually I
probably do with my left oh [ __ ] I just
got hit what again for switching hands
yeah ain't gonna give me what you think
you're gonna get me oh I can understand
how you thought you were gonna get me
well instead I've got a heaping help
like a [ __ ] you I got an abundance of
that not let's you just take that and go
screw yourself with it it's really fun
trust me
Oh God yeah my fingers are getting tired
we're a well weight will we will that is
a lot of alone boys I'm almost dead oh I
can make it oh baby door jeezum 'he's
holy baloney
holy malarkey Oh God
oh man my fingers are cramping up I'm a
little too drunk for this is overall
DUIs
I don't know if I did the best but I did
pretty damn good oh that's cool that's
cool oh that was it well there's no one
like a reward for that there has to be a
reward for that oh that was hard to do
that now okay moving on
chicas oven party yes I want to play it
of course I want to play it of course I
want to play it
what what what am i oh I was supposed to
get the balls is that really what chica
wants chica wants a heaping helping of
balls for her oven yeah let's give it a
go
Oh
[ __ ] bat it's that's hard I don't know
what I'm supposed to do besides catch
him it was like an arrow that's set up
to oven okay if that's something I don't
know I think I already missed out on
some crap but now that I got the Hydra
dildo I think that I'm not gonna have a
problem with this dude oh yes absolutely
please yes I would love that very much
so
room nine camera okay Oh
give you mr. camera douchebag Oh what
you think those are gonna stop me really
really okay what do I got
I mean yes oh god I'm so strong I'm so
screwed nope you're gonna die
what's it how you die oh you died or
that's so sad for you it's almost as if
I'm gray I mean obviously I could have
done that better but I [ __ ] did it
about you yet what happened for them oh
cool keep getting an HP boost well I
mean with this Hydra Dillo it's gonna be
kind of easy okay so I might be able to
plow through this relatively quickly
[Music]
okay so with that in mind whoa just
appeared somewhere what does that mean
these are no random enemies okay so I
need to find a chest somewhere and buy
somewhere you mean not where I'm going
of course okay let me just clear this
last one yeah let's do this let's do it
nether future okay come on come on
coming
okay come on back up again we gotta we
gotta get going we got do things okay
golden path right on that camera golden
path see if I can clear the camera out
because these other ones actually don't
hurt all that bad oh oh
dildo in your face I took the dildo in
my hand and you're done all right there
we go
okay so now that that is that that the
thing I'm gonna end this episode here
remember in the next episode I'm gonna
try to finish it up as per usual because
this is going kind of fast so I'm
assuming that there's gonna be some
ending here but there's a lot of story
to get through like this final part of
the story here and obviously the
grinding is done so I will so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other five nights at Freddy's stuff
that I've done in the five minutes of
[ __ ] boys playlist down in the
description below and as always I'll see
[Music]
I didn't